hey you know people welcome to the
Reuben report I'm still Dave Rubin and
we have three time returning guests
jacqueline glen hello Jacqueline and we
have multiple time I've lost track of
the numbers do you have it that's not
even on I have the numbers written down
right here my chart I'm gonna say around
six six time repeat guests whitney
mixter and we got a lot of stories for
you there's a lot of stuff breaking
right now so we're just gonna get right
to it so of course the Ray Rice story is
obviously the big story in the sports
world and in domestic news right now
so of course Ray Rice from the Baltimore
Ravens he has now been released by the
Ravens as of two days ago he punched his
fiancee in an elevator so let's just
watch the video quick I know you guys
have seen it but we're gonna throw to
that and then we'll break it down
okay I mean I've now seen that thing
probably 20 times and it's awful each
time I mean just her lifeless body when
he drags her out of the elevator
her name is janay Palmer they actually
got married they are married right now
and she released the statement on
Instagram explaining the situation so
let's take a look at that she said no
one knows the pain that the media and
unwanted opinions from the public has
caused my family to make us relive a
moment in our lives that we regret every
day as a horrible thing to take
something away from the man I love that
he has worked his ass off for all his
life just to gain ratings is horrific
this is our life what you don't all get
if your intentions were to hurt us
embarrass us make us feel alone take all
happiness away you've succeeded on so
many levels okay so we still got more
that I want to get to but let's just
start with that part so yes the Ravens
have suspended him now apparently the
NFL did no of the tape for months they
apparently didn't see it until two days
ago that's what Roger Goodell the NFL
Commissioner saying and that's when they
then decided to suspend him
so without getting into all the minutiae
of the NFL and all that's it let's we
have two ladies on the panel let's just
talk about that part of it I sort of
look I sympathize with her of course
that something awful happened to her and
it's their up to them in their private
lives if they want to get married and if
they're in love and if he's truly if
she's truly forgiven him and all that
what do you make of her her statement I
mean she said several things apologizing
for even for her part in it like she
takes responsibility for it and I feel
terrible for her and the fact that she
married him a month after this happened
is crazy to me and I know that the NFL
he said they didn't see the tape until
two days that's it they're claiming but
you really need to see someone getting
knocked out to know that it's not an
okay thing to do I mean because
initially they only tried to suspend him
for what two games right well initially
they saw the tape this is what initially
they claim they saw the tape of her from
the outside of the elevator so they saw
essentially her life with potty just
being dumped there and was like oh maybe
she was drunk maybe she fell we don't
know the goings on and so they swept it
under the rug
they thought they could get away with it
and I think that so just to clarify real
quick so they're saying that they didn't
see the punch okay yeah that's what
there's yeah they're saying that they
didn't see the actual goings-on in there
until two days ago yeah so that's why
initially they suspended him for two
games only now the thing is here like
there's a much bigger discussion that
needs to be had and it's unfortunate
that she's coming back and and feeling
the need to apologize first of all but
also feel the need to just personalize
this I mean I I understand this is very
personal to her and I understand this
issue is going on between the two of
them but the thing that she needs to
understand here and that people need to
understand is being that this is on such
a large scale of things like this is a
discussion that needs to be had
regarding domestic violence and you know
if you're going to you know commit this
act have it be in a public place and
have it be videotaped and you're in a
public forum in general be expect your
ask to be handed to you right so is that
part of the craziness now of just the
general 24-hour news cycle and all that
that I look I'm not privy to their
private relationships so they may well
be in love and trying to build a life
together and all that I can see you're
not even onboard that like you think I
really so I find it hard to call
something love that's abusive like that
yeah so I mean I understand that that
victims tend to sympathize with their
abuser a lot of the times and I think
that's what we're seeing you know happen
right now and like you said it's part of
a bigger discussion on domestic abuse
that we need to have and since it's not
just their private life he's a very
public figure it's a role model for
everyone yeah so if you let someone this
you know well-known get away with it
you're sending a message to everyone out
there that this is okay to happen the
thing is you're also sending a message
here that just don't get caught almost
because the thing is 21 out of 32 NFL
teams have members on their team that
have been convicted or committed
domestic abuse or sexual abuse there's
three cases pending right now you know
between the 49ers player there's a
couple other ones and it's just like
okay this person just happened to get
caught doing it so it I mean I don't
know I think at the same token of the
NFL taking such drastic action and
suspending him the Baltimore Ravens
still
stood up and one of their first
statements that they said was about
janae apologizing and her for her role
in it so it's like even though they
suspended him they're still taking her
in as an accomplice to the situation I
think well it seems very clear to me
that unless there's a video that this
the league knows that there are tons of
criminals and it's not just the league
that all sports they know that there's
all awful stuff going on there's people
doing drugs and beating women and all
kinds of horrible they could literally
start another league just for the
criminals that might be it was like a
battle royale of football you know and I
think but I think the fact that we've
suspended players and I say we because
I'm a chairman on the board of the NFL
for smoking weed for a year and then you
get a two-game suspension for doing
god-knows-what and an elevator until you
see what really unfolded I think is
completely asinine yeah well to that
point so Keith Olbermann
who has a show on ESPN now he is pissed
that basically everybody involved in the
situation from top to bottom so let's
take a look each body each leading
individual involved came to a judicial
conclusion about what had happened to
janay Palmer and what should happen to
Ray Rice and each through deception or
incompetence mislead the public damage
the efforts of every man and every woman
in this country seeking to merely slow
down the murderous epidemic of domestic
violence and made a mockery of the
process by which those who batter those
they claim to love are to be brought to
justice and not one of them not
Commissioner Goodell not NFL's senior
vice president Adolfo Burch not NFL
chief counsel Jeff pash not Baltimore
team president Richard casts not
Baltimore general manager Ozzie Newsome
not assistant prosecutor Diane Roux
Burton of Atlantic County New Jersey not
prosecutor Jim McLain not Superior Court
Judge Michael doe no not Ray Rice
himself no matter what actions were
taken today against Rice nor what might
be taken in the future none of them have
any remaining credibility and each must
leave or be expelled from their current
positions okay well you [ __ ] yeah yeah
I mean clearly the guy is not mincing
any words there I think he makes some
really good points this sort of reminded
me actually
of the whole Penn State sex abuse thing
where it was systemic and everyone sort
of knew and who do you fire and how you
know do you blame the coach and the
president and the vice president and all
that that's for watching that in slow
motion like why exactly do we need an
ESPN like football slow-mo replay of
that like in stock out I just don't
understand like I saw it I don't need to
see it like in slow motion like a
hundred times I get it sort of like the
Isis beheading things it's like we watch
them and like it's gross but you sort of
have to see it things a lot of people
try to sweep under the rug and pretend
doesn't happen but whenever you see it
right there and from your face it's too
hard to ignore yeah do you agree with
him I mean I know obviously we're not
NFL owners and and regardless of your
feelings on sports in general but is
this a type of thing where the NFL just
has to clean house now like they really
have to send a statement like you guys
knew what was going on whether you saw
the video two days ago or even if it
comes out that they saw it a month ago
just get rid of some of these people
absolutely I think these people need to
be you know taught that this is not okay
you can't support it like I said before
you know they're public figures so what
they do reflects on society and people
look to them as an example so if you
don't take care of it when it happens
it's gonna perpetuate itself I mean it's
it's such a large discussion because you
can look into like well why aren't music
executives fired for not you know
tarnishing Chris Brown's contract or why
aren't like politician I mean what
there's so many different sectors of
business and politics and sports that we
would all it would all just shut down
everybody's fired everyone's hired yeah
fire so I'm glad you brought that up
because I do think that's a really
interesting point because I was noticing
how everybody I get all my information
from Twitter these days everyone on
Twitter was clamoring for him to be
fired then he did get fired okay or let
go whatever you want to call it and
everybody was happy but it was kind of
making me think look if this was an
accountant now I get your point about
the public figure part of this but if
you were an accountant and you beat your
wife and there was video of it you would
still be allowed to be an accountant
once the legal proceedings took you know
we're resolved or whatever so is there
something like should we should we be
holding sports people to higher
standards than
regular citizens no I mean I think it's
just the public eye if you're in the
public eye you're and you know fan
dollars and people's money is going to
your salaries and you don't have the
personal power to hire them like I
wouldn't hire an accountant that I knew
was an abuser you know what I mean
and I wouldn't want to go to a game
where I like all the other players but
this douchebag is beating his wife
presenting the team a whole you know
it's a larger picture and they might not
want him to be representative of them
yeah so are you guys down with the idea
that he'll be banned for life I mean
that's what some people are saying do
you think it's like a privilege for him
to be able to play I mean what's up with
homeboy who like was in the dog fighting
and then now he's back with Michael Vick
and now he's back with a vengeance and
people totally forgot it all so who
knows he could be back you know it could
be a passing thing yeah all right well
this story is probably not going away so
we will see what happens but let's move
on to Isis this thing also is not going
away as we tape this tonight President
Obama is going to be making a major
speech on what we're gonna do about Isis
people are saying it's gonna be this
three-year protracted thing and maybe
we're gonna have airstrikes in Syria now
do we need authorization blah blah blah
that's a whole other topic so what I
wanted to talk about was that there is a
bunch of brave people
this started in Lebanon and they are
doing something called the burn Isis
flag challenge it even has a hashtag on
Twitter and let's take a look at some
video
[Music]
okay so as I said this started in
Lebanon but it's it's spreading so to
speak across the Middle East as you can
see some of the people do show their
faces some don't these people have some
ball like whether you're showing your
face or not knowing that everything can
be tracked and traced and tagged and all
that we got to give these people some
credit for having balls right it's
definitely risky but it's interesting to
see some of them using blowtorches the
globe we're not messing around that
seems to be the reaction from YouTube
behind the camera here I have made the
pun and then I kind of stop thank you
for thinking that the follow through
with it I'm sorry yeah
but really we do have to give these
people like these people live in a part
of the world where there is so little
freedom we know what Isis is doing I
mean this was originally a reaction to
them beheading a Lebanese soldier so we
kind of should be backing these people
that are trying to fight the power right
I think it was a group of students that
initially did this and there's a video I
think on YouTube with over a hundred
thousand views and at the end of it they
challenged the whole world
icebucketchallenge style to also burn
flags yeah so everybody out there
watching don't buy a flag though print
it out don't support them right you can
burn a print out copy do you guys think
in a weird way that when people do these
kinds of things that it somehow
strengthens them you know yeah that's
that's my concern in this is that you
know Isis and and these Islamic
extremists and whatnot are doing a have
a huge outreach campaign on social media
to recruit new people and and my concern
in this is that it's drawing even more
social network attention where it's it
could potentially be the those people
that are on the fence of joining or not
or looking more into the other side of
things
that's just my fear in this that it's
just bringing more media where that's
actually been one of their largest
outlets and recruiting new members yeah
so we've been talking about that cuz
we've been doing this for weeks we were
doing Isis before it was cool we were
doing it here really back in May I mean
we were talking about this but how much
of that do you think is true like should
we be talking about this because is it
all you know people they were suspending
Twitter accounts that were posting the
beheading video
and they don't want you know they're
taking them off YouTube and all that
because they think it's propaganda to me
I think we kind of have to talk about it
cuz we need to know what's going on
especially if we're about to enter a
freaking war that doesn't see I don't
want but but but happy yeah but how much
do we have to actually talk about it
without strength in the game I think
it's impossible to have one without the
other
yeah you know so you gotta to have to
weigh it and see what you think is more
beneficial in this case like she said
most of their recruitment is coming from
social media so it is a scary idea but
how else you gonna get the word out
there how else are you gonna try to make
change
and in in reading about this I actually
stumbled across something else that I
thought was really moving which was the
rubble challenge have you have you heard
about that it's a small group of people
and Gaza instead of doing the ice bucket
challenge they actually control where
they you know obviously don't have
access to water or and a lot of them
don't have access to electricity to make
ice so they actually took what something
that they do have access to a tremendous
amount of which is rubble
yeah imported over their heads so that
statement so it I mean this this concept
is catching on it and it does make
people have discussions like we are
right now so I think you know in that
sense it's good yeah although at some of
the more of these that we do are we just
watering down all of them no pun
intended there was a bad pun really like
are are we really I mean you know
everyone's doing this now we have we
have secretaries of state that do hash
tag things on Twitter like how much
actual change is any of this affecting
really beyond just kind of making yeah
the information is good it gets us
talking about of that kind of stuff do
you think it really causes any change I
do and I think honestly the more people
talking about it the better I don't
think there's any watering down effect I
think that you know the conversation is
good to have and if people weren't
talking about it before and they aren't
out that's only positive right yes yeah
all right well then let's end on an
agreement okay all right I'm seriously
pissed about this story and it's getting
completely swept under the rug between
all this Isis stuff and then the Ray
Rice thing so President Obama announced
this week that he's going to push his
decision on immigration to after the
elections in November now why would he
do that now okay so just real quick we
know the
Republicans suck I say it every week
they suck they're not helping they're
not trying to make compromise they're
not trying to do anything now so he
can't get legislation passed that he can
sign to make immigration reform at the
same time he knows that it will be
unpopular for him to do any executive
action now so he's announcing that he's
going to wait to do something unpopular
till after the election to help the
Democrats so this just reeks of
everything that sucks about politics all
around bad Republicans then using an
executive action which is sort of a
betrayal of the separation of powers
it's a lot it's a lot of [ __ ] and it's
just sort of what drives me nuts about
politics in general but let's look at
the White House official statement on
what the president's going to do the
reality the president has had to weigh
is that we're in the midst of the
political season and because of the
Republicans extreme politicization of
the issue the President believes it
would be harmful to the policy itself
and to the long-term prospects for
comprehensive immigration reform to
announce administration action before
the election so you really need to think
about what he's saying there he's gonna
do something that's politically
unpopular that his base wants him to do
right now so the progressives all the
people on the Left want him to do
immigration reform right now but he
doesn't have the balls to do it right
now because he thinks it's gonna hurt
the Democrats the Republicans aren't
playing ball it's just everything as
I've now said ten times it's everything
sort of that sucks about politics
wrapped up and one thing politics just
sucks how's that how's that for a
question just politics just sucks I
think that's all we need to say videos
done that's it no I mean I'm not
surprised because this actually would
hurt the Democrats in the midterm
election so I mean I'm not surprised I
mean what politician makes political
decision for for elections yeah shocking
but shouldn't a president a two-term
president in his six year almost
entering lame status be a little more
brave and say I'm just gonna [ __ ] do
it
like to me it's the idea that he's even
telling us they're flat-out telling us
like we're playing politics in the worst
possible way
do you really think I mean I are you Jen
are you generally upset genuinely upset
are you just playing devil's advocate
here because I
he's just blatantly saying it how it is
we're as opposed to in the past a lot of
politicians have been like having a lot
of empty promises and I'm gonna do and
teetering around things he's just
flat-out saying I'm not gonna do it
because it's gonna mess us up real bad I
think I mean I have to give him some
credit and in that regard of thing okay
so I'll give him that much credit I'll
give him that like you're telling us how
stupid the system is and you're being
honest about that so I'll give him that
it's like a filibuster you know not
taking action in this larger writer I
guess what I'm more annoyed about here
is just that this that he's six years in
and they just never I know the
Republicans suck I say it every week but
like they just never figured out a way
to make anything work so instead he has
to do an executive action you know we
have separation of powers so Congress is
supposed to make laws and he's supposed
to sign them but what he's saying is I'm
just gonna wait till after the elections
to do something you don't want me to do
because it's gonna hurt my guys the
Democrats and then I'm gonna do
something that I don't really have the
authority to do so I guess I'll give
them a little credit for the other and
also also I do my concern in this is
that this is gonna drive more
Republicans to the polls to assure that
they get the slots and it's gonna end up
backfiring and then he's just gonna be
expected so I totally buy that and I've
already seen this in the right wing
websites and blogs and everything
they're all like you see what he's gonna
do you see me Xenu so it energizes their
base so is he accidentally strengthening
the other side what's going on here I
mean maybe the whole thing is like he
said politics sucks Republicans suck
democrats suck everybody sucks I mean he
he is being honest at least and telling
us why he's doing what he's doing kind
of though because he said that he would
have this done before the end of summer
breaking his own promise yeah yeah I'll
do it soon and now he's saying he'll do
it after the elections if he even does
it then maybe he'll keep kicking the can
down the road and that's why people are
mad because he keeps just
procrastinating and delaying things you
know
cutemon civil rights can wait
immigration reform policies to change
quickly since immigration since we
started coming over the borders from on
the Mayflower I've been waiting for
immigration yeah exactly I don't know
the thing is we've literally every
politician has used this as a platform
or a speaking point throughout their
term and it still hasn't happened but
we're just focusing on him cuz he's like
yeah I'm not doing it right now so just
hold up you know he said it just like
that right so my mind yeah isn't it just
sad though that a president six years
into it still has to be playing politics
I guess that fundamentally is one of sad
things about a lot of presidents that
we've had so yeah alright final thought
on this solve immigration for me what do
you guys think because I think this is
also what nobody ever talks about on the
news is what do actual regular people
like if what do you basically think
about immigration what should we be
doing like basically because there are a
lot of people who are doing it legally
you know so you don't want to make them
feel like you know what's the point
everybody's just you know sneaking in
anyways and there are a lot of criminal
issues that come into play with this but
you have to remember that we are a
nation of immigrants so everybody who's
high-and-mighty who thinks that all they
need to go back to their own country
where do you think you came from yeah
that's what they told me in third grade
yeah we should we should nourish safer
avenues for people that have been here
contributing to society for them to
become legal citizens and you know and
then we should strengthen borders and
and make the there there be a more
streamlined process of having legal
channels I mean it's really about making
it a safer space for people who have
been here you know to actually like move
forward with establishing citizenship
here it's like making it a safer place
for them to come out and say it because
it's so taboo and people who have been
here for 20 years still are you know
tiptoeing around around the applying for
health care applying for different
things that's like these people are just
as American as your I yeah I mean
literally they're separating families
that
here for 20 years and they then deport a
kid who gets pulled over for a stop sign
yeah I basically I agree with both of my
esteemed guests on this one yeah let's
secure the borders let's just get that
secure if we can possibly do that and
then figure out a way for all the people
that are already here to announce it and
let's get them in and then we'll deal
with everybody else and I know that's
kind of high on this guy's stuff but I
have a feeling maybe we can do it with
an executive action or some other
half-cocked measure our great ally Egypt
I'm very conflicted about Egypt I think
they're kind of trying to do some good
stuff they've had you know between coos
that maybe did happen or didn't happen
and you know what's going on with the
new president they're they're they're
sort of trying to be a good country and
then they kind of go backwards a little
bit they just arrested seven people
after their first gay wedding let's take
a look at some video
[Music]
[Applause]
[Music]
[Applause]
[Music]
I mean that's the sound of joy people is
that the sound of joy that would be a
good that's a great lesbian that's like
the call of the lesbian I don't make
that sound well let's just assume that
was a good sound I think it was a good
sound there we don't never get those
images out of the Arab world something
progressive happening and joy and gay
rights so there's a lot of good there
but of course then these seven people
get arrested
the Public Prosecutor's Office released
a statement saying that the act was
humiliating regrettable and would anger
God Jacqueline I know you're gonna have
a field day with this God fella they
remained in custody for up to four days
and it's a little bit unclear what's
gonna happen to them now by the way
Egypt and they're not the only country
in the Arab world that has this and they
have medical tests medical tests for gay
people where they try to figure out if
you're gay and I don't even want to get
into how they do that but we've talked
about it before
to me this is the type of story that
everybody in our media should be talking
about all the time because you know when
when Russia had the thing and their
Sochi Olympics everyone was going crazy
and yet for some reason when something
good starts happening in the Middle East
we don't talk about it and we should be
talking about this shouldn't we and and
bringing to light what they're doing but
also showing that there are little rays
of light coming out of that place yeah I
mean you saw the video they seemed so
happy there was nothing wrong going on
in that video but they were still
charged with what publishing indecent
images really yeah and I'm pretty sure
it's not about the video that they put
up it's about the actual act that
there's they're representing them as a
country and their people and I think
that that's where you know those people
can't genuinely be tied to our nation
and whatnot I mean this is a blatant
example of human rights violation in so
many regards like I actually did look up
them what the medical testing you know
and and it's like making these people
get on their hands and knees
pantsless and massaging
stimulating essentially and penetrating
their anal cavities and like that sounds
like a good Friday night that sounds
really like I'm just saying like that
it's literally in so many aspects of
things if that were to happen anywhere
else I feel like we would be talking
about I think it's because it's the
middle east area right now I think
there's other other situations that are
trumping it and they don't want to I
don't know so what are you making that
how we pick and choose these things so
we're all outraged and remember we were
boycotting vodka even though it turned
out that Stoli vodka was made in like
Latvia or something but we were
boycotting the wrong vodka company
because we were so upset about what they
were doing the gays Egypt they're doing
this homosexuality is illegal in every
literally in every Arab country I think
there's ten that you can be put to death
in in Africa so why don't we get upset
about this I think people live in a
little bubble that we call America and
we don't really look at what's going on
in other places and as much as we should
people just don't think it applies to me
I live here you know they're all there
so far for me it doesn't apply you know
for some reason people just care less
and that's sad but I think things like
this are great because we can get
discussions going and hopefully bring
more attention to it
yeah why do you think there's an obvious
connection to where they treat gay
people well is pretty much all the
places that civilized people would want
to live what's the connection between
being okay with gays and then pretty
much everything else being sort of okay
there seems to be a through line there I
mean I think it's a more just a more
libertarian mindset a more openness and
and you know free speech free action it
is allowed and people enjoy freedom so
you know if if you can live your lives
and and and be free and be happy it's
just the place I would want to flock to
that area as opposed to flocking to you
know Egypt or the Middle East where I
have to wear like a full cover I don't
know I mean this isn't the first time
this has happened either where it's
actually been there's been a larger
scale arrest in 2001 there was 52
arrested on some luxury boat of a gay
club in Egypt as well and it's just like
get gay people to death last year I mean
yes I mean the fact that this is still
happening is
that needs to be brought up as a
worldwide discussion like I think that I
think that those countries that do have
the liberties of being who you are and
being out and being gay and living your
life I think should this should be an
area that should be interjected on yeah
I mean that's my opinion maybe that's
because I'm part of this community also
invested into it but then again I feel
the pinyon if it is my student union it
is but I feel like if there were
lesbians and they were doing this it
would there wouldn't even be a video
because they'd be like women exist
yeah maybe totally shot so we just did a
segment on immigration do you think we
should treat gay people in other
countries and countries where it is
criminalized as refugees if these people
wanted to have refugee status should we
grant them that I mean personally I
would say yes just because I'm worried
about everybody I feel like you know
what I feel so bad for what they have to
go through and it's not right and I
would love to help them but I find it
hard to believe that we would do that as
a country when we still haven't
legalized gay marriage everywhere here
it would just be like a big Priscilla
Queen of the desert run through from all
different countries just full of like
you know worldwide Queens yeah sounds
awesome
sounds like a documentary I want to make
speaking of a documentary I want to make
they're giving weed away to poor people
in Berkeley California yeah that's right
we've got a little more info for you
marijuana dispensaries will be required
to give 2% of their pot to people
earning less than $32,000 per year the
measure is destined to provide pain
relief to the needy who cannot afford
prices that reach $400 for an ounce of
legalized weed the regulation was passed
last month by the City Council
it takes effect next summer I want to
give a shout out to our director Mike
who got very excited when we showed that
right there okay look we do a lot of
weed stuff here I smoke weed I have no
problem with weed like the weed you know
once I did it once
oh yeah just once just once just once
for you what marijuana for you and I
would imagine since you got rid of your
dreads no I'm clean you're totally clean
slate yeah
okay so there's just something kind of
funny about this story I guess in
general like that the government would
be giving weed to poor people so let's
just get the funny stuff out and then we
get up like is there something funny
about this there's something funny right
like we need to poor people it's medical
marijuana so it's well you're
technically supposed to be serving a
purpose yeah medically right I mean you
know so you're trying to help people out
but the only the only issue I kind of
had with this was forcing businesses to
give away 2% of you know their product
which you wouldn't normally do but I
heard from a bird through the grapevine
that sometimes when you go to these
places they give you free joints anyway
so might not be so bad I might do that
they told me you never know so getting
away from the funny part of like just I
just had this vision of like there would
be homeless people that we'd just be
getting them stoned all day that just
seems funny to me somehow great think
about it this way I mean we either state
aid given to these two poor people who
can go in and get prescriptions filled
that are things that are way more
serious you know narcan's like you know
oxys or adderall or you know things that
really can affect people and really good
stuff not really good no I mean
seriously like this is and these are
medically these are regulated things
that large companies make a tremendous
amount of money on still you know with
these people coming in with their state
insurance and I feel like this innocence
is amazing because it's taking big
business out of it and I I think that's
that's making huge strides in the whole
industry in general
yeah narcotics is one of the number one
killers of acts like accidental death in
America you know so for people to be
worried about marijuana that killed
anyone ever right I mean you know like a
giant like face-planted and
I've never like died from that obviously
cuz I'm sitting right there if I ever
smoked weed that was deep winter you are
usually do smoke weed I mean we're we
don't we do a weed story we talk about
that that right people don't die of weed
it's just they don't they don't even get
into car accidents because of weed they
sit there and they eat and they laugh
and that's it I'd be more concerned on
people wasting their food snaps much
faster so what about the people that
would argue it's gonna kill their
motivation because there is probably
some truth to that you could smoke weed
and you sit there and watch cartoons
instead of going to get a job and doing
what you should do to be a productive
member of society bait on Fox News about
this and that's exactly what the pastor
was saying what are we gonna we're gonna
we're gonna make all these people out
there who don't have a job even more
lazy yeah I mean they're probably not
gonna do less things now because they're
homeless report they're there in these
situations because of you know medical
problems that they have or other
problems in their life it's not just
because they're lazy and that's a big
misunderstanding a lot of people have
they stigmatize you know people who are
lower income and they call them lazy
when that's not the case I agree on a
serious level visit and medical
marijuana actually does have positive
effects on things like cancer and
arthritis like very real Parkinson's I
mean so it's like these could act this
could actually be a beneficial
alternative treatment that is actually
saving taxpayers money and helping
people at the same time so I'm all for
it
alright so we're pretty much all agreed
here yeah we're all agreed on the weed
do you think years from now that the
people that are against legalizing weed
forget this the poor person angle here
but the people that are still fighting
it now are they gonna be looked back and
just thought of as totally ridiculous
yeah we're probably gonna look back on
them in the same when we look back on
people who are all for the prohibition
yeah you know I mean freedom freedom
right um yeah
free love free love there you go alright
let's talk about the US Air Force I
thought this one was kind of interesting
the US Air Force has told a sergeant
that he's gonna actually have to leave
the military unless he agrees to take an
oath with the phrase so help me God yeah
I'm not making that up no other branch
of the military forces their members to
do this but the US military but the Air
Force does he's refusing to do that and
now he's poised to take the military to
court
Jacqueline obviously has to start with
you on this one what chip or the
separation of church is yeah there's
that thing that we call separation
people don't even realize what that is I
don't think I mean how could you really
sit there and expect somebody to have to
even put their hand on a Bible when
they're going under oath to your version
of God you know what if they want to put
their hand on a Bible for you know Thor
or some other ridiculous made-over than
God yeah I mean I pledge allegiance to
the flag you know one nation under Thor
how about that let's do that right so
should we I always say we should have to
swear on the Constitution that would
make a little more sense those are the
law all right that we're supposed to
live under but instead it's just this
imaginary book and I don't even mean
that to denigrate religious people but
it has nothing to do with our laws so
what is what is about the US Air Force
that that's the one I thought was
interesting here that it's not the other
branches of the military it's just the
Air Force it's the only one that
specifically the Air Force I mean look
what is it about them that they are they
the most and they're flying around up
there like no I don't understand it all
and I can't believe this is still still
in place and you're saying why can't
people understand this it's a separation
between church and state because there
isn't actually a separation between
church and state in every inner
courtrooms in you know and our Pledge of
Allegiance yeah in our classrooms it's
like it's everywhere yeah and by the way
for people that might think that things
are going in the right direction in
terms of church and state actually in
the past you were allowed to use
alternative phrases instead of so help
me God
but they changed their policy in October
2013 yeah less than a year ago they made
this thing more religious so that's sort
of the order that we're going here do
you think it really though is it a
violation of the Constitution I mean if
this guy's gonna sue and I think he's
gonna win yeah he should win it is a
violation it's blatantly not okay to do
that I think there's somebody here
willing to risk their lives for our
country and he's actually being forced
to go against something he believes and
you know he's giving it been given
ultimatum I think he absolutely has a
case and he's it absolutely went yeah
all right well we've got a little bit
more on atheists because 1/3 of
Americans want God taken out of the
Pledge of Allegiance I thought this was
really interesting yeah actually the
phrase under God was only added to the
Pledge of Allegiance in 1954 so it
wasn't always there contrary to popular
belief and there was a study on this
let's take a look at findings the
American Humanist Association surveyed a
thousand Americans after being told
those words were added to the original
version 34 percent said under God should
be removed 66 percent said it should
stay and of the thousand respondents 666
oh the devil the devil the devil
identified themselves as Christian 123
as followers of other faiths and two
hundred eleven were unaffiliated so to
your point a second ago about we don't
even have separation of church to say
directly that's what you were saying
actually does this pot as an atheist
when you see the Pledge of Allegiance
and they and does this bother you does
the phrase bother you yeah it bothers me
because it's you know this is not one
nation under God this is one nation with
a variety of different people with a
variety of different beliefs or lack of
belief so why would we want something in
there that's exclusionary and I liked I
liked you know the American Humanist
Association saying that there were a
third of people that wanted it out that
made me feel kind of better but at the
same time I thought was kind of [ __ ]
like I mean I'm used to being in such
like a Christian society and stuff and I
kind of looked into their numbers a
little bit I'm like this just doesn't
make sense no way is a really a third of
people out there who want this to be
like that
they said something like just real quick
are you sick are you saying that because
you think that numbers low like you were
surprised I thought that was high yeah
because I'm sure I'm like shocked that
I'm like this I'm saddened by the fact
that it's so low I couldn't believe it
was as high as it was I thought that was
absolutely like I was like did they
fudge the numbers to make it look more
favorable towards you know secularism
and they said that what's 666 were
Christians with a thousand so that's
what roughly two-thirds yeah but that's
not right because 83 percent of the
population in America is Christian so
their numbers are skewed a little bit so
use right so their internal polling data
you're saying is skewed right yeah but I
mean I think you can be Christian and
still want the word God taken out yeah
well I guess you could be anything
I think it's not about that I think you
can be Christian and just still be you
know open-minded to the fact that this
is essentially becoming a statement of
faith instead of a pledge to our
allegiance of nation you know and and
that's not what it's supposed to be
about and you get into freedom of speech
issues in my opinion you know when
you're you're making children I'm I'm
sorry I know people say that kids aren't
required to say the Pledge of Allegiance
but maybe things have changed in the
couple of years that I've been a child
but I I mean I was forced to say the
Pledge of Allegiance every morning with
my hand over my heart like it was like
that was what you were doing even if you
didn't if you were the one kid that did
it well then you'd be bullied all day
for not doing it right or or suspended
or something but really it's amazing to
me that we don't have the debate more
about why don't we say one nation under
the Constitution that is though the book
that is the document or just want it out
altogether mean the whole thing wasn't
there before like we 1954 yeah so why do
we need to just add that in just take
the whole segment out one nation
indivisible with liberty and justice for
all yeah is it does it have something to
do with kind of like if you throw God in
there then it's kind of like you can
make people believe anything like one
nation under God whatever it means
whatever you want it to mean so it's
sort of how like if they were to put
constitution in there then our
politicians would actually have to
follow the Constitution but they don't
have to they have to follow God
I think there's usually
God in their mind the way that they
legitimize it is that they use God as
like this big balloon term and God being
the nation that we live in like the
omnipotent presence that we are part of
but at the same time it's like not
comfortable for some people to say that
you know I mean like imagine if all
those Christians had to say like one
nation under Allah or whatever and some
people would be uncomfortable well
imagine those people being put in that
situation it's the same thing it should
just be an in descript term majority
rules mentality and with eighty percent
eighty three percent being Christian
it's kind of difficult to get around
that sometimes and I think there was
actually a similar study done before
this and the result was like what eight
percent people said they wanted to have
it taken out right so they jumped from
eight percent to thirty four percent so
an amazing Goods happening here actually
is that I just sort of shocked but okay
so the point of this was to show that
with education people's minds would open
to wanting to take it out so the poll
originally that got eight percent as a
result they didn't educate people and
tell them that it's been changed since
1954 so what the American Humanist
Association did was they said hey this
didn't always used to be there this was
something that was added in it wasn't
always there and with this new
information the point they were trying
to make is that people were more open to
saying okay well then maybe we should
take it out because it does seem weird
that it's in there because I guess it
wasn't there all along it's almost as if
if you educate people they become
smarter well I hope we've educated you
guys a little bit and more importantly
than any of this don't forget the
seventh commandment which was sent to us
directly by God which is subscribe to
the channel the button is right down
there below Jacqueline and Whitney
they're Twitterers are right down below
so check them out and thanks for
watching and we'll do it again next week
[Music]